are you speaking of the WNBA there's a  video of a shot going around talking  about the WNBA he goes I have a way to  make it equal the WNBA they have all the  pieces to have a really good League they  have Shooters they have ball handlers  they have finesse there's no dunks we  just lowered the rim so y'all can dunk  like we dunk we put butts in the seat no  I don't think that's the problem that's  what Shaq said he's thinking basketball  not thinking why people want to watch  [ __ ] yeah you're a jiu jitsu guy right  yeah the good thing is women should just  do it's actually popping but like let's  say it wasn't from a jiu jitsu lens  you'll probably be like oh yeah there's  fork and more arm breaks people are  going to watch it more no if they're  doing Jiu Jitsu naked the more people  will watch it you know I didn't say that  Anthony did but the record